as I waited for the preview build of
ukulele to load i busied myself checking
Twitter and replying to emails there was
some music playing from my childhood I
couldn't quite remember I racked my
brain was it from Donkey Kong crash
bandicoot maybe banjo kazooie when I
looked up I realized I've been listening
to the song that greets you on ukuleles
Start screen and as I spent the next 90
minutes playing through a guarded demo
of the first two worlds I was hit with
wave after wave of nostalgia it's no
secret why this game taps into those
classic early 3d platformer memories
either made by platonic Games a company
made up of several key rare devs from
the n64 era ukulele is billed as a
spiritual successor to their most
cherished work from the past in ukulele
you play as the kind and sensible
chameleons UK and wisecracking bat laily
like banjo kazooie each member of the
duo has unique abilities you could can
eat honey or cannonballs and absorb
their properties allowing the team to
stick to slippery surfaces or withstand
powerful gusts of wind leili can use
sonar to reveal hidden platforms or flap
her wings to carry the pair across large
gaps just like jam jars in banjo tooie
abilities are unlocked through the
merchant character trouser a snake in a
safari hat that's squeezed into a very
tight but very sensible pair of shorts
he's not a charity either you need to
spend some of the 200 quills you can
collect from each of the games five
worlds to unlock any of the abilities
you need trouser quickly emerged as my
favorite character as he's prone to
answer his mid 80s cell phone mid
transaction or give the jaw advice
complete with superfluous esas because
he's a snake you're going to need all
the advice and abilities you can get
because ukuleles worlds are enormous
each can also be expanded with pages
another of the game's suite of
collectibles reminiscent of games like
Mario 64 or donkey kong 64 each world is
an open arena just begging to be
explored a forgiving checkpoint system
means an ill time jump or misjudgment of
distance doesn't see the last 10 minutes
of traversal going to waste exploration
is always rewarded to whether it be with
a new collectable a hidden cart racing
mini game or an encounter with one of
the many supporting characters there's
the scientist with octopus arms dr. paws
who can transform you Guren laily into a
twisted sentient flower in order to
pollinate other flowers Nimbo the cloud
needs help to make it rain because
they've lost their confidence and Clara
a skeletal explorer needs to be rescued
from a pot before she's tonight's dinner
every interaction animation and line of
dialogue is dripping in the same
sarcastic absurd humor rare was famous
for I kept catching sight of my stupid
ear-to-ear grin whenever Leigh Leigh
would crack wise with a meta joke about
Kickstarter money or modern games
reliance on tutorial levels these jokes
are delivered in classic rare fashion by
a scrolling dialog boxes accompanied by
varying squeaks and squawks it sound as
though their pitch shifted from the same
sample I'll cute at first it can quickly
get tiresome but thankfully you can
speed up dialogue with the press of a
button cutscenes are also delivered in
this way but the fantastic animation and
visual gags kept my attention throughout
speaking of you'll want to pay very
close attention as you play one of the
first boss battles you'll encounter is a
simple quiz against dr. quack one of the
game's main villains while similar to
grunty's furnace fun from banjo kazooie
or any of the quizzes for that matter
the new quiz has been expanded and now
adds in questions that are unique to
your playthrough for example I was asked
which ability i acquired first how many
total quills I'd collected and in a
classic nada banjo I had to identify a
location from a screenshot each time a
new question appeared I turn to other
people in the room and we excitedly
conferred about which we thought was the
correct answer ukulele is a game that
feels equal parts familiar and new it
captures the spirit and feel of the
games that defined rare in the n64 era
and brings them into the modern video
game landscape be sure to check out our
gameplay videos of ukuleles first two
worlds and subscribe for all of our
coverage on ukulele and video games in
general I'm Dan and I'm going to go and
play a bunch of banjo kazooie to tide me
over until April 11
here
[Music]